y bueno muy buenas tardes y también
saludarle a toda la ciudadanía
radioescuchas
ellas ya llevamos 18 días de esta
movilización nacional una movilización
pacífica una movilización sin violencia
ya que el día lunes iniciamos el diálogo
y ahí a la noche se cree se cortó
prácticamente el diálogo y nosotros
estuvimos pacíficos esperando el diálogo
para dar paz al ecuador
entonces el día de ayer en la noche
justamente el gobierno nuevamente
anunció el posible diálogo para hoy día
y eso hemos cumplido una agenda bastante
tensa
en la cual también sea el movimiento
indígena se ha pronunciado también en
algunas algunos temas y entonces la cual
se ha sido mencionada que todos los
temas que son generales pero la que se
va a ser más específica estaremos
tratando en las mesas técnicas de
acuerdo de acuerdo a los 10 puntos pero
hemos logrado los 10 puntos
una lucha colectiva que es victoria de
todos los luchadores de toda la
ciudadanía quienes han sumado a este
gran esta gran jornada nacional de
movilización y estamos también
agradeciendo a todos nuestros compañeros
amigos de los sectores sociales se me da
hay unanimidad dentro del movimiento
indígena en cuanto a estas negociaciones
y estos resultados
bueno nosotros como conaie dirigente a
nacional con toda nuestra estructura
hemos desde el inicio de bueno desde
siempre hemos manejado la democracia en
la cual siempre ha sido consensuada para
poder dar esta firma en la cual el
presidente leonid así se ha podido
firmar y cómo vería usted la actitud del
presidente lazo desde el inicio de las
protestas hasta el día de hoy con estos
resultados
desde inicio de la protesta el
presidente guillermo lanzó siempre nos
acusaba los dirigentes siempre ha
manifestado de una manera
discriminatoria de odio hacia los
pueblos y nacionalidades en la cual
nosotros no nos hemos callado en
nuestras voces y hemos sido bien claros
también que nosotros no nos callaremos
mientras que el ecuador no tenga mejores
días porque la lucha no es sólo para el
sector indígena la lucha es para toda la
ciudadanía ecuatoriana más bien muchos
ecuatorianos algunos ecuatorianos
también se han tergiversado la
información y también hay personas que
también aún está obstaculizado esta
movilización pero en la cual nosotros
hemos mantenido bien resistente como os
caracteriza el movimiento
movimiento indígena porque la lucha de
los pueblos ha sido siempre reivindicar
por los derechos hoy la lucha ha sido
por una justa razón
y que están y que estos diez puntos se
cumplan y así hemos logrado hacer estos
diez puntos se ha podido lograr que ha
sido victoria de todos y la lucha de
todos y como continuarán desde el
movimiento a partir de ahora con sus
acciones harán un monitoreo de que se
cumpla lo pactado y como lo harán de ser
así si es el movimiento indígena siempre
va a estar pendiente vigila de con los
actores que quedaron como
veedores para dar cumplimiento a estos
10 puntos el estado ha propuesto para 90
días pero nosotros vamos a exigir y no
vamos a dejar fuera esto por lo que no
esto por lo que hemos firmado quizás un
acuerdo esto no se queda fuera de la
lucha nosotros en cualquier momento
estaremos luchando en este gobierno en
otros gobiernos porque eso ha sido el
deber del movimiento indígena y hemos
caracterizado también pues sólo para
buscar
mejores días para la ciudadanía
ecuatoriana